so this is the area that we're after
okay now simply thinking about it I mean
if you remember back to image of Radian
measure right this is not that hard if
you were asked for instance to work out
what's that little slice or me and
that's called the segment okay the way
we work that out is you work out the
bigger shape first right so the secret
is going to be the sector that's the
slice of pie and then you subtract the
triangle that's left over right and we
used half a b-side see to get a result
and then you get your results at the end
which is what is it half a square theta
minus sine theta as long as you're
radiant anywhere so being that this
conversation is exactly the same as that
it's just a subtraction of erient okay
here's what I'd like you to have beside
your diagram to this what do you say
this is equal to really if I work out to
other areas and then take their
difference now one of the areas you need
to know which one's a bargain which ones
will work because you want to know which
one to use subtract from the other okay
now strictly speaking I suppose it ought
to be true to say this if you got them
the wrong way around
okay you could sort of just slap an
absolute value one right because if you
have them the wrong way around can just
get a negative and we know- areas don't
make sense so here you just whack an
absolute value on it and you're fine can
anyone tell me why in the case of
integration and functions that might not
be such a wise idea because because
they're both on popping below each other
is that what days ago what you get for
you okay now okay you're good pair
cannot even case you miss that case you
miss that it's both reasons it let me
try and explain a filing cabinet okay
House Representative over here's the
first problem is the first problem to
simply put the absolute value science on
top and ignore which one is above and
which ones below okay it's problematic
because well at different points you
know if I drew a little further at
different points what is above emily and
they change right so at this point X
squares both then X bar and the next
square takes over again okay so just why
can absolute value sign it ignores like
what happens if we take a domain whether
area changes okay that's a problem
secondly we know that actually when you
integrate into a definite integral
negative area inverted commas sort of
does ever me right it's what happens
when things are under the access yes so
if I move this x-axis right suppose we
changed it from you know if I find it
plus more
+1 something like that ok so just
removed it like so ok now if the
question was ok what's area it's still
going to be the same area but I just
moved so the value the size hasn't
changed ok but the definite integral is
changed you see that because some of
this the negative part is going to start
to cancel out the other part so if you
just simply subtracting and whacked
absolute value signs away you're going
to get quite a different result so
actually value signs will have their
place but later on when were the more
functions that we have water but you
don't want to just chuck them on with a
million okay you've got to be very
careful so coming back to what we
actually wanted to work up going through
ok what are the two areas i'm interested
in well like we said in this domain the
part that's above is why it was X so if
we just considered on its own what
you're going to get is that trailer
to get the actual area that I'm off top
i'm going to subtract this krabby bit
underneath okay so if i put this in
another color here that area there but
it's loaded right that's just
considering the parabola
okay that's the area right so I'm gonna
start on my right hand side here I know
what these two integrals ask separately
right I think that's all that's one more
or something right so therefore my my
expert 20 to one day my boundaries sorry
so how many degree from 0 to 1 all right
and this function is X with respect to X
because that's the access that are
bounded by ok then orders to track this
area 0 to 1 of X swear yeah ok so going
back to the properties we just proved
namely 35 ok we come back over here and
say the difference between two intervals
to definite rules ok it's just the
definite integral of the difference
which is what we saw in differentiation
what's deputies anyway
okay but can you see as an area problem
it comes up quite differently right so
this is going to be easier to evaluate
because once I do the integration we
just have to do one set of square
brackets rather compare their customers
so whenever you have a closet area you
want to go through this process now in
this example it's simple but why you
pulled me if your redone you went
straight here but later on when you get
like if it's underneath the access and
you want to go further past the point
where they're on what is clearly above
the other switches robot okay you have
to be very careful in how you form is
definitely to it okay to make sure you
get my answer all right Seth essential
for every section it would be clearest
but you can use your properties of
definite integrals sometimes depending
on the kinds of functions you have to
come by a lot of these integrals
together carefully